well I always uh here I go I guess I you
know what I like to do please I like to
I do a nice back stretch where I take my
I I lay down you know and you take this
and you go oh that one's great yeah way
over there here hold that no dude oh and
then oh I'm doing it right now and then
I do it the other way and you got to
keep your opposite shoulder down yeah I
did that one too yeah I like that as
well sometimes Molly hates doing it but
I was like you know my wonderful wife
Molly I'll say hey babe could you just
get on this like whatever you could be
on your phone we could watch a movie
whatever you want just please get on
this knee and dig it all the way over
there hey you know this would be a good
time to fart right into the mic Chad
let's see if this goes here look at that
look how the mic goes right to my
[__]
[__] I don't want that oh this is
gonna be awesome when it finally happens